this week's honest trailer is brought to
you by dnd beyond dnd is for everyone
dnd beyond makes it easy to play
register for free at dnd beyond.com to
start your adventure
[Music]
from the studio you know the one there's
only like two of them left now anyways
comes a series based on silly comic
books like what if iron man fought king
arthur or what if wolverine was a
vampire that dares to imagine something
even more ridiculous what if mcu writers
could try something new
but not like new new just a slight remix
of some old favorites let's not go too
crazy here
marvel's what if
enjoy some wild animated experiments
that stay true to the mcu by having no
real beginning or end no real message to
get behind and every character from the
most hardened warrior to the most
powerful cosmic being speaks like an ai
barfing out chandler bing dialogue i
simply abhor drama your outfit would
suggest otherwise
uh
guys i'm covered in sharon
do you guys just not have horror movies
in wakanda we don't need them we have
american reality shows boom goes the
dynamite
right now you're running at an eight and
i need you to take it down to a four
your team building instinct slipper yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's held to hr
okay i don't sound like that that is so
not true
that happened
meet the watcher the other extremely
powerful comics character who swore
never to intervene in human affairs that
we're meeting this fall
hi
he's a messy who lives for drama
and this jeffrey ride-shaped planetarium
will guide you through alternate
timelines like what if england had a pop
culture icon who wasn't a sociopath what
if every franchise was better without
chris pratt what if all the avengers
died and also agent coulson was a five
on the kinsey scale he's a caucasian
male mid-20s with really great hair it's
an accurate description he's gorgeous
steve steve steve i heart steve even
while rotting he smells like lavender
what if the universe headed out for
rachel mcadams you know doctor
what's-her-face what if she was the key
to all of this any interest what if
zombies you guys still like zombies
right sorta okay how about this one what
if killmonger the most sympathetic
villain in the entire mcu was just
destined to become evil like no matter
what someone should have killed him in
his crib what do you mean this isn't
working for you fine we'll do it your
way what if ultron stole vision and
chopped off thanos arm and ate the
universe and was like whoa i'm going to
eat you too and the watcher had to be
like not on my watch and they start
punching and adventures fly out and the
robots get hit with the shields again
okay wait you good do you little content
piggies get what you came for
come on why are you crying oh right this
is a show for kids i forget that
sometimes kick back and listen to find
out which of your favorite actors needed
to pick up an extra check during covid
don't play the fool with me fury michael
douglas really then get genuinely choked
up when you realize you're hearing
chadwick boseman do t'challa for the
last time it doesn't feel over and
finally wonder what dave batista did
that caused disney not even reach out
all right principles but regardless
thrill has a bunch of million dollar
voices emerge from heroes who look like
the characters you pay 10 bucks for at a
town fair because walt disney's built
its entire brand on top quality
animation everyone deserves a break now
and then it's been a tough year are we
sure they didn't buy dreamworks too
you know what's hot right now the
multiverse and after endgame helped set
up the idea of the multiverse and one
division teased the possibilities of the
multiverse and loki explained the scope
of the multiverse and doctor strange too
gives us multiverse madness what if
we'll drive the message of the
multiverse home even further we're all
one of an infinite number of variants
going through the same
our struggle seen only by a voyeuristic
space walnut who could save us from our
fates at any time but won't wow there
had to be an easier way than killing
free will to explain why terence howard
can't play roadie anymore or whatever he
thinks one times one is two
so if you want to see your favorite
marvel characters and exciting new
stories that stretch the imagination buy
a comic book but if you want more of the
things you already liked combined with
other things you already liked resulting
in something slightly less than the sum
of its parts well what if there was
nothing else to watch until eternals
comes out
wow
look at him stand there can't wait
starring
i only watch the multiverse for the
articles you captain america
the cat is the pratt someone please take
this man's driver's license
[Music]
glove death and robots halloween three
season of the witch scarlet no hansen
gundam wang
futurama did it
asgardian pie
pricario
hentai squid and this is what happens
when you mess with a mouse robert you
have to die
but why
male ducks have corkscrew penises just
putting that out there i now pronounce
your darcy and a duck
this week's honest trailer is brought to
you by d d beyond d and d beyond makes
it easy to play register for free at dnd
beyond.com to start your adventure
i
love
honest trailers takes written no
mistakes it means they should win
and twins